think the snyder cut was the first time
an angry mob bent a major studio to
their will back in the 2000s sci-fi fans
pulled the ultimate hail mary for a
series they loved this is the untold
truth of serenity
long before his name became synonymous
with his behind-the-scenes behavior and
years ahead of his rise to prominence as
the creator of buffy the vampire slayer
joss whedon was a workaday hollywood
screenwriter he penned a few roseanne
episodes a few episodes of the original
parenthood and got his big break on the
writing team for the now classic toy
story whedon then shifted his focus to
writing sci-fi with alien resurrection
the fourth installment of the
intergalactic horror franchise in
resurrection series protagonist ellen
ripley played by sigourney weaver
encountered a crew of space mercenaries
bearing more than a passing resemblance
to the firefly crew while there's not a
one-to-one comparison between the
resurrection gang and the serenity crew
let's say mal and his associates are
kind of like buffy to resurrection's
faith it all just goes to show elements
of firefly existed in whedon's
imagination way before the early 2000s
in some ways the real world story of
firefly and serenity hinges on the
technological acceleration of their era
social media was in its infancy of
relevancy in 2002 but that didn't stop
whedon's very online fan base from
getting loudly perturbed about fox
canning their new favorite show you suck
as facebook wouldn't be invented for a
few more years firefly fans nicknamed
brown coats in homage to the independent
planet's army from the show's mythology
had to rely on digital message boards
and forums to vent their indignation
biographer amy pascal said i believe it
was one of the first instances where the
producers reached out and asked fans for
their help to save the show similar
online campaigns eventually rose up in
attempts to reverse the cancellations of
cbs's jericho and nbc's community over
the years fan backlash rightly or
wrongly directed at film and tv studios
expanded into a potentially terrifying
force of its own the most notorious
example being the campaign for zack
snyder's justice league a new edit of
justice league which had credited
wheaton as its primary director
ironically online fan rage became
relevant in the entertainment industry
because fans wanted more of joss
whedon's work and its biggest moment
came at the hands of fans who wanted his
work replaced with someone else's
angry ranting on the internet is well
and good but on its own it wasn't enough
to convince movie studios and producers
that firefly had a large enough audience
to support it on a new network you
couldn't find evidence of firefly doing
strong numbers on hulu either because
there was no hulu in the early 2000s but
dvd sales were one quantifiable metric
that could gauge the popularity of any
movie or tv show upon its release
firefly the complete series which
helpfully included the three episodes
that never made it to air in the u.s
crashed through the 200 000 unit sold
ceiling pretty quickly an ign article
from around the same time states that
amazon burned through its supply of
firefly dvds on pre-orders before they
were officially available for purchase
for a series that was poorly promoted
aired in the wrong order and axed after
about four months that's quite a lot of
box sets the comparatively surprising
retail boom established a perception
that firefly contained untapped
potential as a franchise in some form
while he came to the table with more
than 30 episodes of directed television
to his name the cinematic follow-up to
firefly marks whedon's debut as a major
motion picture director some 15 years
into his emergence as an active
hollywood creative professional even
after 2005's serenity he didn't direct
another movie until the avengers in
total joss whedon has directed four
films the comparatively low budget cult
film serenity the hugely popular
avengers and its sequel avengers age of
ultron and much ado about nothing a
zero-budget shakespeare adaptation he
made at his house with actor buddies for
a lark dudes had a weird career of
course whedon also wrote serenity
describing the process as an unusually
challenging endeavor he said in an ign
interview in 2003 whedon explained i
want to tell a mythic and exciting and
timeless tale about nine people that the
audience has never met and yet not
betray or repeat anything i do on the
series it's going to be tough as far as
a fan and critical consensus goes it
looks like he pulled it off although
films reaching for the same visual scope
serenity targeted typically cost north
of 100 million dollars to make in those
days universal encouraged whedon to
locate production in a cheaper country
to keep costs down in defiance of such
conventional wisdom whedon insisted on
shooting in his home city earning him
some good press and goodwill from the
los angeles community somehow he
reportedly delivered serenity to the
studio for less than 40 million dollars
whedon's other demand was that the
original cast returned to their formerly
tv roles which wasn't a problem as the
universal executives overseeing the
project took an if it's not broke
approach to the serenity roster of
actors nathan fillion's job most
assuredly was locked in it has since
been revealed that alan tudyk's
inability to sign on for a sequel is
partially to blame for wash's tragic
fate knowing what we know now that makes
the end of his story extra sad without a
serenity sequel wash died for nothing
sarah paulson plays dr karen a scientist
who reveals the alliance inadvertently
created the ultra-violent race of
ex-humans known as reavers their
aggressor response increased beyond
madness they have become
well they've killed most of us this
brings about a plot twist that
transcends the movie to impact the
entire franchise mythos so despite
appearing on screen for less than two
minutes before dying horribly dr karen
is an extremely important serenity
character this isn't quite an unknown
background extra going on to become a
major hollywood commodity paulson was
already well established among the ranks
of tv and film actors before she landed
this brief but highly memorable part in
serenity but ryan murphy had yet to come
into fruition and therefore paulson was
not yet able to star in virtually every
ryan murphy-related project nor had she
achieved her current movie star status
so although sarah paulson wasn't exactly
an unknown before her appearance and
serenity she definitely secured a key
serenity moment during her on the way up
phase the folks in charge of determining
what did and did not stay on the fox
network in the late 90s and early 2000s
don't exactly have a spotless track
record canceling family guy after its
first pair of seasons is the most
glaring example of their questionable
competence but they also canned arrested
development and futurama two other
programs now considered classic comedy
staples if serenity had panned out as a
cinematic juggernaut spawned a string of
sequels and turned the cast into
bonafide movie stars fox executives
would have had to face up to how hard
they botched the firefly rollout instead
serenity failed to surpass the 40
million mark so after you factor in its
promotional costs serenity was a net
negative for universal for reasons
totally independent of its quality
serenity simply didn't click with
mainstream moviegoers
yes
i don't get it
so if the fox execs thought firefly
would be wildly beloved by a sci-fi
fringe but never attract enough viewers
to justify spending at least a million
dollars per episode to keep it on
network tv serenity tickets stubs
confirmed to their suspicions while seth
macfarlane made fox execs look clueless
joss whedon may have done the opposite
doing press to promote firefly reruns on
basic cable back in 2011 nathan fillion
mentioned to ew if i got 300 million
dollars from the california lottery the
first thing i would do is buy the rights
to firefly make it on my own and
distribute it on the internet he did not
assume anyone would take that statement
literally or seriously he assumed poorly
as it turned out many people took him
literally and seriously and an online
fundraising campaign to buy firefly and
give it to nathan fillion promptly
sprouted legs and started jogging
phillian himself had to tell folks to
power down fillion further explaining
himself in a follow-up interview said
would i want to do firefly again yes do
i want people sending in money no
if we can judge the success of a tv show
and or movie by the jobs it's cast
scrounge up after the fact then firefly
and serenity did better than their
ratings and box office returns might
indicate after eight seasons in the
titular role of castle nathan fillion
currently stars in the rookie gina
torres went on to join the cast of suits
and guest starred on westworld riverdale
and hannibal among other tv shows alan
tudyk voiced k2so in rogue one a star
wars story and routinely provides voice
acting and or on-screen cameos for other
high-profile sci-fi superhero slash nerd
stuff marina baccarin showed up in tv
shows like homeland and gotham and was
the female lead in deadpool arguably the
most surprising superhero smash of the
last decade after appearing in a pair of
episodes as malcolm's wife saffron
christina hendricks broke through on tv
screens in the role of joan harris on
mad men
of course there's some idol noncommittal
executive chat about a firefly relaunch
but as of this writing there are no
announcements or credible rumors
indicating an imminent return of the
serenity to any screens be they big or
small this might be for the best
in the eyes of some the show's legacy
may have benefited from its abbreviated
run as nathan fillion himself mused in a
2015 esquire article firefly as
short-lived as it was never had an
opportunity to suck it didn't have that
oh well season two was kinda slow it
picked up in season three and season
four was great with hollywood endlessly
rebooting relaunching and rehashing any
established property it thinks is worth
another penny maybe the big streaming
nostalgia machine really doesn't need to
frack 10 more episodes of firefly out of
joss whedon 20 years further into their
careers the original cast might be
expensive and difficult to schedule also
if fans have learned anything from the
final seasons of arrested development
and the x-files it's that more isn't
always better firefly fans got 14
episodes and a movie maybe that's plenty
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]